I good afternoon all right so we are not
getting too many customers don't know
why my name is John Kerry I'm associate
professor in the computer science and
engineering department of UT Arlington
there I'm also directing the database
and information systems research
laboratory well at UT Arlington my
research focus on several areas related
to big data in the data science so that
include databases data mining
information retrieval and web data
management okay the theme of our
research is on building human assisting
and human assisted large-scale data and
information systems with high usability
k high efficiency and application for
social good and today so these are
several projects that we are currently
working on today I'm going to talk
mainly talk about one of these projects
computational journalism okay and data
science applications in computation
generation I have three scenes to
confess okay number one the title of the
talk mentions crowdsourcing so if you
come here for things related to cows or
see I'm not really going to talk about
it so that's due to some
miscommunication number 2 i'm not really
an expert of python i use the python
playing years ago when i was a student
okay for my PhD dissertation work and
for part of the project okay and my main
focus is on tweaking the call our
database engine of mysql and postgresql
okay and there i use the c++ and java
and so on and in the next 10 years i'm
many focus on doing research writing
grants writing papers and so on didn't
really do
much programming is actually not much in
Python but then started from several
months ago I would say maybe half a year
ago okay I picked the Python again for
several reasons one is I happen to be
the chair of our publicity committee of
our department and you know part of that
responsibility is I need to manage our
or oversee our department website and
another aspect of it is that I get to
use social media and claim that part of
my work ok so that's about publicity and
I need to I needed to put up a list of
areas in our department that are ranked
high nationally and internationally so I
got information from Microsoft Research
Microsoft Research a search api and i
use the python to download their web
pages and extract ranking list of about
10 20 major research areas in computer
science and how these different computer
scientist in this country are ranked and
then figure out how ut-arlington
strength right so there I use the Python
and use something called a beautiful
soup and which is fairly effective for
information instruction okay that's
number one number two for some of my
research projects I needed to use Python
to explore various ideas the number
three in this master when I teach data
mining I I used n ot k and used
matplotlib and I ask my students to
implement a design fees and increment
clustering algorithms to a
classification and to natural language
processing using various Python tools
and because of that I need you to design
design programming assignments using
Python so I got more familiar with spice
on these days and so that's the second
thing I want to confess number three
some of the slides that show codes
limits the code snippets and not
produced by myself they are actually
produced by my students and actually all
the sauce called return for this project
so far I down by my students so I
mentioned that for acknowledging the
great contribution from my students also
as a way of excusing myself if some of
the slide doesn't make sense right okay
so computational Jordan this is a
collaborative project with several
people at Duke University Stanford HP
Labs a Google research and so on
starting in 2010 what is computational
journalism why computational journalism
in a very simple and short way
journalism is in crisis traditional
journalism is crisis many because of
competition from internet and new type
of new types of media so there is a
reduction significant reduction of
profit and and then eventually reduction
of resources in traditional journaling
so the goal of computational journalism
is to use innovations and techniques in
computation to help reporters and
journalists in doing their tasks in
making their work more effective okay
and we have been focusing on two aspects
of computational journalism why is fact
finding and the other is fact-checking
and in fact finding is about funding and
monitoring important and significant
fact facts then there is a event taking
place in the real world okay
fact-checking is about discovering and
verifying the choose fulness and the
robustness of factual claims that people
make all the time okay and I prepare
some size for fact-finding but I think
I'll skip then I'll focus on our fact
checking if you are interested and we
still have some time I can come back to
these slides about fact-finding okay so
fact-checking people make claims number
based the claims are factual claims all
the time it's virtually politician okay
so this is a area that interest
journalists and reporters are
particularly so this statement made by
Mitt Romney in one of the presidential
debate in 2012 he said our Navy are the
Navy US Navy I smaller than it has been
since nineteen seventeen right so the
general public and the reporters
interesting no invader this is to all
fours right it turns out this is not a
simple and easy question it's quite
tricky this figure or chart is from one
of the reports related to this claim
right and you can see the number of
battleships that US Navy has starting
from even before 1972 icing 2012 recent
years and unsurprisingly there is a peek
at ev'ry World Water second and there
was you know there were significant
increase during several other major Wars
and its own and after that the numbers
have been declined ok so the claim that
Mitt Romney made is that the number of
battleships oh you know US Navy is
smaller the smallest things about this
point so it's not exactly correct but
it's not
the far right so this number is quite
small in this whole period if we use
this information source then we can
pretty much say that what he said is
true however you know we need to realize
that you cannot really compare the
battleships 100 years ago with nowadays
battleship right so even though the
number of battleship is smaller it
doesn't mean the US Navy smaller so
that's actually the opinion of experts
on you know then then one fact-checking
website our polity fact checked
whiskey's experts and the consensus is
that this claim is pretty much force ok
it's invalid and so this is what their
website put up you know fire appends on
fire so that means is significantly
force ok there are several existing
fact-checking projects this one I just
mentioned perhaps is the most well-known
polity fact and there are several others
journalists and reporters they spend a
lot of time doing this ok checking these
claims that people make in chem hands in
debates in interviews in news articles
and so on ok and what we want to achieve
so I gave this project the name of claim
bastards just something that I came up
yesterday right so it's not really a
permanent name that we were used but
anyways the goal is to automate fact
checking process imagining that we get
claims from all kinds of texts source
our speeches debase interviews social
media and news and we will classify
sentences and statements and rank them
based on how likely they are factual
claims and
how important their topics are okay and
oh maybe how likely they are force also
will produce a ranked list of factual
claims and then journalists can go ahead
look at this this and spend their time
on the more important ones or the highly
ranked the ones okay but of course we
also develop automatic algorithms to do
fact-checking automatically or part
partly automatic okay and this can be
you know this can even empower the crowd
into in fact checking for instance we
can ask Twitter users whether you
believe this claim is true or not if we
can get opinion if we can collect
opinions from a large number of people
then that can can tell something about
these claims okay and we have a plan of
deploying some service for the election
that is coming up next year right and
you know if this can be accurate if our
ranking and classification algorithm can
be accurate that will help reporters and
general list a lot and help the general
public a lot I'm going to talk about the
progress that we have made so far right
many about our classification models for
funding check words affect your status
and we had we had also we had also made
some preliminary efforts on using
crowdsourcing particularly using Twitter
to to check factual claims but I will
not talk more about maybe this is the
only thing we led you to crowdsourcing
today the by the way if you have any
questions just interrupt me and ask me
okay
so here's the problem we are looking at
we want to classify factual claims and
at this moment we are using one data set
which is presidential debates are
transcripts and these transcripts can be
obtained from various sources this is
one of such source right so there were
certain the 30 debates for election 11
elections in history so so the earliest
debates were in 1960 and then it stopped
for a while and then starting from 1970
we have been constantly having
presidential debates for every election
okay so there are totally saw database
and every debate of course involves two
speaker two candidates there are about
20,000 sentences made by these
candidates in all the presidential
debates and we have removed the very
short ones those having less than five
words will not consider part of the data
set so overall there I think about 40k
thousand sentences very short ones and
the sentence is made by moderators of
debates okay so this is our data set and
we want to classify each sentence into
one of the three classes okay and are
you familiar with a machine learning and
the notion of classification kk raise
your hands okay so that's good so that
makes my job much easier so these are
the three classes there's no factual
claim in this sentence okay I'm not
showing the sentence here I'll show one
specific sentence later right but this
is a question we will ask will the
general public be interesting no
inverter part of this sentence is true
or false right so that is the prediction
we want to make that is the class labor
we want to keep to each sentence
and there are three possible labels no
factual claim a sentence containing an
important factor claim and a sentence
containing important factor plane so
these are examples of sentences for
these three different classes right so
these are important ones these are our
modern wise you know we spend less on
media territory than any time in our
history this is pretty much similar to
what Mitt Romney made and you know I was
in I over yesterday that's a fact your
claim but perhaps not so interesting
important for the public to check and
these are opinions and questions and
declarations they are not truly factual
claims right so I will be tough on crime
right so that's not really factual our
plan is to reduce tax rate by ten
percent so that's a plan that we will
execute but it's not fact this is how we
collect our ground choose data so we
have set up our website okay and this is
one sentence among the 20k sentences so
we will show are these sentences to our
participants and ask our participants to
label all these sentences they also get
a chance to see the context of this like
the five sentences before this right and
they also have the option of skipping if
they're not confident in giving a label
to this sentence and they can also have
a chance to modify their labeling okay
our goal is to get each sentence labeled
by two participants okay and we are
still doing that we have accomplished
about eighty percent of our job okay the
ground choose will include the sentence
only if the sentence is labeled
consistently by the two participants ok
so if both say that this is important
then we say yeah
I consider that to be the ground to
label for that sentence if they
disagreed then we will not use that in
training our model and in testing out
one so well this is how we use Python in
this project okay we use n ot k which is
a python-based and natural language
toolkits for getting structured data out
of the debate transcript files for our
tokenizing the sentences and for getting
part of each tags out of the sentence
okay and we stole extractive features of
sentences into mysql database using
something else in other packaging python
we just met plot lead to to plot our
classified performance which will show
we use alchemy api to extract features
for each sentence okay so these are the
features these are the input to our
classification models the features
include keywords of course part of
speech tags sentiments of sentences
entities in sentences okay and you know
the concepts that these entities about
and furthermore taxonomy of topic of the
sentences and we use psyche learn to
build our classification models so I'll
give you some more details about how we
do each of these so this is a CODIS
limit of using an otk to do
part-of-speech tagging and to do
tokenization of course before even doing
that right so this is one very simple
sentence okay we can use arrow TK to do
tokenization and then a pure is tagging
and this is a result the tax we are
getting for that sentence if you were
here in the last session then you
seen something similar okay so for
instance tax is a non and policies are
none okay and ease it's a word and
baddest adjectives and so on right so
these become the features of this
sentence so in this particular case we
have 12 we have how many terms yeah we
have nine features related to POS
tagging that will become input to our
classification model this is how we do
our sentiment analysis using our alchemy
API right so it's really simple the
sentence as the input text is just to
say that this is the textual format
instead of HTML and so on right so other
options can be HTML maybe Jason I'm not
exactly sure okay and this is how we get
our this sentiment and we can show we
can print out this and sentiment for
this sentence its net if for sure
alright so it's very inactive so this is
a high in active value and this is how
we extract named entities from sentences
using alchemy avi okay so for that
sentence okay what you are seeing is a
the tax policy this phrase is unnamed
entity right it's a named entity of this
time I'll feel the terminology basically
it's a terminology in a particular field
okay and it has a relevant score to the
sentences 0.33 relevant to the whole
sentence and we also get in the our
sentiment out of it so basically for
each entity in a sentence we can get the
sentiment score of it whether it's
positive or negative right so this is
different from
the houghton that hose and answer the
sentiment but in this case in this
particular example since it's short they
become the same and this is how we get
the concepts right so named entity is
full funding whether a sentence has
entities that are people organization of
places and so on but doesn't say which
particular person it is right and
concept is to say that that particular
term refers to this real world entity
that we know about let's say there is a
particular wikipedia-ing for LeBron
James then the concept will say at this
term LeBron refers to that Wikipedia
entry so that's different from named
entity recognition so this is the output
of that simple sentence once again now
this this was the sentence we looked at
the tax policy for the middle class is
bad right okay so we see middle clause
and we see social clause and they have
different relevant scores middle class
is more relevant than social class two
distinct ends and meter clause has a
particular meaning it refers to this
real world entity in dbpedia in freebase
and the open cyc I don't know if I've
heard of any of these all of them are
knowledge bases and taxonomy is similar
to Wikipedia right dbpedia is extracted
from Wikipedia and free base is a
community constructed collaborative
knowledge base instead of encyclopedia
and open cyc is some singular you know
some project similar to freebase but was
done much earlier than freebase so
anyways this way we rebuild connection
between middle class as a phrase with
particular concepts in these knowledge
bases
so these concepts become the input
become the features to our cliff
classification model okay and finally we
fund texana Me's of these of topic
taxonomy of the sentence so that
particular sentence is related to law
government and politics and further
related legal issues and further related
to legislation right so alchemy API they
have a predefined taxonomy of topic a
topics right so low and gun in the
politics this is one of the root topic
in their taxonomy and under that you you
know we see some sub categories then
legal issues is one of them not really
showing its below this and then
legislation is further below legal issue
so these three things become features of
that sentence will become input to our
classification models and then we use
cycle learn to build the classification
models right we have so far we have
tried three of machine learning
algorithms 90s classifier support vector
machine with linear SVC right so that
uses a linear kernel and for multi-class
classification and then we also use
random forest classifier and
particularly we used two hundred trees
in random forest and this is our set up
and so we have three classes a sentence
being belonging ascendance belonging to
one of these three classes right NFS not
in fact your claim no that means not
important and yes means important factor
grade and we use five categories of
features okay so these are the ones I
mentioned keywords of course NTD types
okay purist tags concept taxonomy and
then we try to five combinations of
features so basically we consider
keywords to be basic and then we start
to add into the stack of features that
we want to use so we add
POS tax upon keywords and then further
include entity types and further include
concepts and taxonomy so there are five
combinations and we always use
sentiments and the lens of the sentences
so they're not mentioned as these five
categories of features but they're
always used in our classification model
we have 1500 sentences are in our grant
you so far so remember these are the
sentences that have been labeled by two
participants and they agree on the on
their labels ok so our we have tried a
four-fold cross-validation right and the
ratio between training and test data is
three versus one right so since you are
familiar with machinery I'm not going to
explain what this means okay and this is
you know snipped it again of how we do
these right so we have theta and
multiple columns you know each column
corresponds corresponds to a feature so
each row in data is one sentence
essentially we do not want to include
the last column because that's the crunk
juice that's label of each sentence but
the rest of the columns are the features
we want to use right and this is how we
this is our ratio between training and
test data you know seventy-five percent
of the sentences will become Jenny and
the 23 many 25% get on to test data
alright so we use random numbers to
decide each which sentence should be put
in training data which should be which
then it should be included in test data
right so just how we partition the data
and then these two are trained verdict
and test verdict these two lists they
are they are the labels the gonk use
labels of sentences and if we use
scikit-learn it's truly simple too
to get a classifier right Road random
forest classified that's the function we
use for putting random forests and this
is number of trees that we want to use
in random forks and this is a 90s
classifier and just as we in classified
now if you just use that to replace this
you get a different model you start to
replace that you get that you very much
and you just say that we want to use
train as the training data and this as
the crunk you label and a model will be
created and then you predict using that
model to predict for every sentence in
test data you get the prediction that is
how you do hand out by partitioning data
into train and the test data subsets
then this is how we do cross validation
all right so there is a particular
function called across well score in
cycler for for you to do that and so
these are some results as I said this is
fairly a preliminary our goal is to get
all 20,000 sentences labeled and
hopefully that will allow us to get
better classifiers we also explore more
different types of classification models
and further tune these classification
models but anyways these are the results
we have so far and this is on precision
all right so I guess everybody
understand concept of precision if we
label a sentence as important the
percentage of sentences label that
labeled as important data truly
important right so that is precision and
these are the results for three
different classifiers svm IFC in a 90s
classifier and you have you know for
each classifier you see three group of
five groups of boss for five different
combinations of features and then you
know we have the precision on three
different categories of sentences right
it turns out no is the most a challenge
category of sentences so that's natural
right because we have NFS which means
that sentence doesn't have fact you
claim at all and then yes which means it
has an important fact your claim and in
the middle it's no so it's easy to get
confused and you know so that's the
ambiguous case it's relatively less
challenging to get a sentence in NFS and
yes correctly labeled so so the
performance all know this category is
not really impressionable satisfactory
so that would be one area that we want
to focus on improving though it looks
like RFS okay ifs and and svm have
better performance than nya bayes
classifier okay in terms of a precision
and ifs seems to be seems to outperform
SVM as well okay if you look at the no
classes okay and RFS is better that this
is rico so that's a different matter
right so out of all those sentences that
are truly yes how many are labeled by
our algorithm or models as yes okay and
you know that would be the red bar and
we do that for the three classes
corresponding to the red green and blue
bar and here we see some interesting
results and vc it turns out to be
effective in terms of rico so it's fine
it finds a lot of it fun finds a lot of
less important factual claims okay you
know in terms of that is better than SVM
in ifc but of course it suffers on the
other two categories NFS and yes okay
and other RC random forest it doesn't
appear to be effective on the null
clause ok let's see as we n is stronger
than I of C are in terms of that and oh
we combine precision regal and we get F
major
so this is a magic for combining
precision recall it is essentially the
harmonic meaning of precision Rico right
and we see steel RFC is the best for yes
and NFS in terms of F major okay but
it's not really strong on no class and
MVC is the best don't know class but in
DC really suffers on the other two
categories of sentences okay and here is
you know this is the point that I want
to do some advertisement and want to get
some help from you i was hoping to get a
larger audience okay but you know any
help is help to us you know if you can
you know go to our data collection
website create account ah and you know
this is the short URL and this the
sister what's the name of it are the you
use some code okay it you can go to our
a survey website and create account and
basically this this will be one thing
sentence that you label and here you
will see how many sentences you have
labeled and we even have a leaderboard
based on our ground choose data will
rank users based on the quality of their
labels and their surprise associate
wasters right so each sentence you
labeled will give you our entry in our
random join or price so you know we have
some grand prize which is twenty dollars
we have some second part we 100 all
right then if we get enough participant
we plan to get more prize okay so you
know I think it's really fun I even
participate and label some sentences and
its really interesting and educational
to see how challenging it can be in
telling whether a sentence has a fact
your claim and whether it's it's
important or not okay and you know as I
said this is a collaborative project
with a lot of peep
from several organizations tilk stanford
columbia chinese academy of science and
google research these are our graduate
students in my group that are that have
contribute contributed to this project
so far right so really the you know the
program's the coding is done by them
particularly by nine or her son okay and
you're our project funded by NSF
National Science Foundation and HTTP
laughs the Chinese Chinese version of
NSF basically and you challenger as well
so this is some disclaimer that we
always need to keep to you right so this
is not whatever I say is not opinion of
these funding agencies and that's my URL
at my homepage and my email and my
groups home page n you know if you can
help us that would be truly appreciate
it and thank you very much for listening